uh dave rubin is a former
leftist i guess who now voted trump and
i guess is like kind of friends with don
jr
and dave rubin
um known to some of you as you know a
cultural critic or or an arbiter of
ideas
he said yesterday or the day before
that the unvaccinated are now being
treated like the jews right before the
holocaust except that there aren't yet
gas chambers and he's referring to the
protests in canada uh and the truckers
and and this entire thing now there are
people who are going to say wow dave
rubin is jewish so we should be
listening to what he says about the
holocaust because he's just no what he's
saying is just wrong
um and uh we should be
um critically analyzing what he says and
let's take a look at the video clip and
this this is exactly again it's the same
reactionary kind of fear porn that we
talked about just minutes ago i just
said to my guys as we were playing this
it's truly incredible watching these
people flip the story and how they
reverse everything they say about one
thing when it's their guys doing it
versus how uh they say it when it's the
other guys doing it first off i just
want to say something very very clearly
please
um i lost family members on both sides
of the holocaust okay i grew up around
holocaust survivors now you guys
understand this this is in a sense
identity politics i don't want to be
labor this point but i don't want to
miss it they love to say
identity politics is toxic
anytime anyone says as a woman of color
i believe or as a you know as as a as a
trans black person i believe they say
that's terrible that's identity politics
reuben is doing it here
he's about to give us his view that the
unvaccinated are being treated like jews
before the holocaust and he tells us
i lost family in the holocaust he's he's
playing identity politics he's using his
identity
to make us believe that he is more
trustworthy in his opinion when they
decry that very mechanism
when they perceive the left is doing it
do not miss this key point
they're against identity politics except
when they do it i'm well versed in what
the holocaust was and what the
demonization there you go people is
um although
the guy who was interviewed there and by
the way great cherry picking on that
daily show and then they they cherry
pick that on the daily show
and then of course they throw that to
cnn because they're all in on it
together i believe they're both owned by
viacom it's just one big circle jerking
out so there's big you know conspiracy
there of course um
just for regardless of what the guy said
whether whether you think he said it in
a butchered way or or he shouldn't say
it or something like that
the way something like the holocaust
starts is you otherwise people right you
keep otherwise otherwising them you say
oh you can't be part of the economy you
can't own a store you can't do this
we're gonna demonize you you're diseased
so it is not a giant leap okay it really
is not and i don't care how much hate i
get for this it is not a giant leap
after two years of demonizing certain
people who wanted choice medical choice
and choice used to be thought of as a
good thing um to compare them to the
jews before the holocaust it's not a
perfectly symmetrical
situation no right there aren't gas
chambers in canada yet yes okay so it's
not perfect there is no analogy to the
holocaust or the pre-holocaust era in
europe when people just are told to get
vaccinated first of all remember that
what he deliberately or out of ignorance
ignores here
is that the holocaust was based on the
reality that jews were fundamentally
pick your word right inferior
unclean
disease-ridden
demonic satanic whatever fundamentally
at a core
level
what's going on with the unvaccinated is
just like hey we think they're making
kind of a dumb choice there's nothing
inherent about the unvaccinated they
they're it's not by birth that these are
there's there's there's quite literally
no analogy whatsoever and
this is my if if you want to play the
identity game
reuben says i would know about this
because i'm jewish no this is that much
more gross because you're jewish
and if you want to be accurate the way
the holocaust started was uh
straight up sort of like racism
against jews and extreme german
nationalism and of course this type of
nationalism is much more prevalent on
the right in the united states than than
on the left um
the the
uh last thing on this is
it's always the fear of the slippery
slope there aren't gas chambers yet but
vaccine requirements point in that
direction it's a false slippery slope
false slippery slopes are hallmarks of
reactionary thinking look they keep
telling us the vac any vaccine mandates
will lead to totalitarianism
but look at the history of vaccine
mandates in 1777 george washington made
the smallpox vaccine a requirement for
soldiers in 1809 massachusetts put in
the first vaccine mandate in 1855
massachusetts put in the first school
vaccine mandate in 1905 the u.s supreme
court decided in jacobson v
massachusetts cambridge i believe it is
can require vaccines in 1977 childhood
immunization initiative started
requiring certain vaccines for schools
and it's never gone further than just
sometimes we require vaccines there's no
there's no concentration camps there's
no gas chambers there's none of it so be
very skeptical when they use the idea of
this is opening the door up to xyz
well if that's the case it's been uh you
know more than 200 years since vaccines
were first required in the united states
and it's not been a slippery slope so
all of this stuff hallmarks of
reactionary thinking understand it don't
be tricked by it find me on twitter at
dpakman and let me know your reaction